we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our next caller from the 8 5
8 area code caller from 8 5 8 introduce
yourself and tell us what's on your mind
today
hey David this is Kevin from San Diego
alright and I recently read about reza
aslan who worked for CNN he got fired
yeah for saying some naughty things
about Donald Trump on Twitter yep and I
know he's someone that you idolize and
admire very much and I was wearing if I
could get you I was warned trying to get
your thoughts about the whole ordeal
listen I so we've done video I have no
problem with reza aslan personally in
the sense that i don't know the guy I've
criticized things that he said and I've
tried to do it in his fact-based as
possible away so when I found out that
he had made these aggressive comments
about the president on Twitter and that
CNN decided basically you know they
called it parting ways a mutual decision
to part ways if CNN hadn't thought that
it might be good to part ways I don't
know how that it was mutual even though
it said it was mutual I have no problem
with the comments the guy made on
Twitter I mean I want to be say exactly
do you remember Kevin exactly what he
did say on Twitter about Trump yeah it
was basically after the London attack
and Sadiq Khan said something about
police and to not be worried
and then Trump said all this is why we
need to travel ban and it rather said oh
the skies of Pisa and you to disgrace to
humanity and he's a man-child who should
be ignored in times of crisis things
like that yeah I mean listen I'm not
offended by those comments I think that
by and large what reza aslan said is is
accurate it changes my views zero
percent in terms of the prior criticisms
of reza aslan
and CNN as a private company can do
whatever it wants and if they say hey we
don't want people on our air who are
saying things like this then by all
means I defend their decision but I have
no I'm not offended by what reza aslan
said you know what i mean and it makes
sense coming from CNN because they try
to do this false balance we're in the
middle
type thank you so they don't appear
liberal that's true yeah yeah so listen
I mean am I glad reza aslan got fired i
don't know i never watched his show i
have no idea whether it's any good or it
isn't
am i offended by what he said no do my
views change on the critiques I've
already made of him the answers also
know there Kevin okay great well thank
you so much David all right thank you so
much for the call very much appreciate
it